You've seen how to use breakpoints in single stepping, to run your program in
slow motion. And of course what you really want to be able to do is look at
variables. I'm going to rerun the program until I hit this breakpoint, here I
am, and over here in this window, you can see the settings of the local
variables. You can see that count is 0, end is 3, and this Boolean inside vowel
group is false. Up here you can see the settings of the instance variables, of
the class whose method we're currently in. Go ahead at home and do exactly what
I just did. Run the program until this breakpoint. Then click continue one more
time until this breakpoint is reached for the second time, and tell me what is
the value of end when you reach it.